bastante lento avanzan estos conteos y
usted lo mencionaba bien Nevada y
Arizona serán los estados donde se va a
definir la carrera al menos al senado
sin embargo en cámara de representantes
hay algunos condados en California
también en el noroeste de Estados Unidos
que también pueden ayudar a inclinar la
balanza a favor o en contra de los
republicanos o demócratas lo que vemos
en condados de California por ejemplo de
Nevada es que los demócratas Perdón
entre más avanza el conteo más van
ganando terreno en estos condados que
pues le podrían dar sillas adicionales a
los demócratas en cuanto a la a esta
cifra mágica que tienen que alcanzar de
218 escaños para lograr la mayoría pero
que pues según los pronósticos no serían
suficiente teniendo en cuenta que en
Estados como Arizona como Nevada la
ventaja aún cuando el promedio es que
sea se ha contado cerca del 70% de los
votos pues sigue siendo a favor de los
republicanos es decir que lo más
probable es que en los próximos días
después de contar condados importantes
de Nevada de Arizona los republicanos
aseguren esa cifra mágica de 218 votos
218 puestos en la cámara de
representantes y aseguren la mayoría en
la cámara baja en cuanto al senado
Tendremos que esperar a la segunda Ronda
de elecciones en Georgia para definir
esta elección y qué reacciones de
líderes políticos y de funcionarios se
han producido tras estos comicios y en
medio de este conteo
pues reacciones bastante importantes
sobre todo en los republicanos el
círculo interno de Donald Trump a pesar
de que Donald Trump salió a decir que
pues estaba contento con los resultados
le están diciendo que por favor el
anuncio que va a ser el próximo martes
de lanzar su candidatura presidencial
como lo dijo que lo haría desde mar al
lago y se lo están diciendo porque
precisamente de muchos críticos
republicanos dicen que el hecho de que
Donald Trump haya insinuado varias veces
que se iba a lanzar la presidencia hizo
que generar una posición reactiva de
muchos demócratas que salieron a votar
Precisamente en contra de los
republicanos no tanto por su candidato
demócrata Así que le están pidiendo al
ex presidente Donald Trump que demore
hasta después del 6 de diciembre cuando
ya se defina la segunda vuelta en
Georgia el anuncio de volverse a lanzar
a la presidencia para los demócratas sin
embargo pues esto ha sido muy bien
recibido y lo que están empezando a
hacer es ver dónde ganaron bueno En qué
condados en qué estados ganador terreno
para pues enfatizar aún más su trabajo
en esos lugares de Cara a las elecciones
presidenciales del 2024